I'll just create a couple.
And it's going to shake the phone.
Do the shake gesture.
A little weird.
This time the spiders did
flee from the screen, but
instead of spreading out radially from
the center, they crossed over the middle
to exit off the screen, and
that's not how it should work.
They should be spreading out
radially from the center.
Let's look at that again.
We'll create some more spiders.
Woah, okay.
It looks like we have another problem.
Maybe the bugs aren't being deleted, but
we'll look at that in just a second.
Let's shake it again, and
that's the same problem.
So this is probably related
to the disperse animation.
Let's go ahead and take a look.
So I'll stop at this point,
just need to stop for a second.
So here's the disperse bugs animation,
and
we can see that we're setting
the off screen position.
And whatever this off-screen position is
being set to, that's what we're trying
to update the bug frame to is
this new off-screen position.
It's causing the bugs to cross
over the middle of the web.
So right now we're taking the bugs
center coordinate to calculate this off
screen position, we're taking the bug
center coordinate, the X, and
we're subtracting it from the view
center coordinate for X and
we're multiplying it by -20, and
we're doing the same thing for the Y.
We're taking the bug.center.y,
and then the view.center,
it's y, and
we're also multiplying it by -20.
So let's try this calculation by hand
and see what it really looks like.
So let's say that we have this
fictitious view in spider and
that the spider's enter,
it's X, is maybe 180.
And let's say view centers,
it's X is maybe 150.
And if we subtract these two
values we get positive 30.
And if we multiply that by
negative 20 we get negative 600.
And with a new center
value of negative 600,
this would cause the spider to move all
the way from it's position to where it
currently is across the center to some
point all the way over here on the left.
So think that's our problem.
Instead, I think if we multiply maybe
by a positive value, we can move
to the right, away from the center
instead of left, across the center.
So let's go back to the code now and
fix this.
So I'll change these to positive 20's,
and once we build and run again,
create a bunch of spiders,
and simulate shaking device.
And nice, there we go.
All the spiders are now running away
in a radial pattern like we wanted.
Now there's one last bug
which I think you noticed,
it's maybe more of a lack of
implementation instead of a bug.
But when we tried shaking the bugs and
then created some more,
we noticed all these bugs came
running back onto the screen.
So, where are these
extra bugs coming from?
My thought's maybe we're
forgetting to move them.
So let's just check back in
the visual debug controller.
And see if our hunch is correct.
So we go to the empty bugs from view.
That's where this should be happening.
There we go.
Model that.
I left a message to remind myself, and
I haven't done it to empty
the bugs from the view.
In this case, I'll forgive you if you
copy the code over from the final
working version because
that's what I'm about to do.
This should just be a simple fix.
So if we go up, it debugs from view.
Here we go.
Let's put that in.
Try it one more time.
And create some bugs,
shake them off the screen, and
then if we create some more,
should be no new bugs crawling back on.
Looks good.
Let's do a couple of different types
of bugs, just for checking sake.
Shake them off, and
everything looks good.
And that's it.
That's all the bugs that I know that
are in the visual debugging scene.
And I hope you're able to find and
fix all these bugs on your own.
But most importantly, I hope that
your confidence is growing, so
that you can go forth and
when you're faced with bugs like this,
or any bugs in your application, you
know what tools are available to you,
and you can use them to
debug your applications.